hi i'm piccola and today i'm super
excited to talk about securing your apis
using google cloud's apogee and cloud
armor
let's get to it
so why are apis so great well
api significantly reduced the time to
market of new innovations and
experiences
by providing a simple and easy way for
developers to consume data
and functionality that resides in your
backend systems
because apis are packages of business
critical information
they are also targets for malicious
attacks
google cloud apigee also saw over 170
increase in abusive api traffic in the
past year
to help you protect apis against
security threats
google cloud brings together apogee and
cloud armor
the best of api management and web
application firewall solutions
while apogee offers oauth api keys and
role-based access
and many other api level security
features
cloud armor offers network level
security
such as ddos protection geofencing and
mitigation of owasp's
top 10 risks let's see a quick demo of
how this works
for the purpose of this demo i have
created a hello world api in apigee
to protect this api let's first start by
adding a verify api key policy
to this proxy once we do that you'll see
the default is set to a query param
let's change this to a header
now going to save it as a new revision
and deploy it to the demo environment
to consume this api let's create an api
product
and add our api proxy to this product by
specifying the path
with this the hello world proxy is now
ready and accessible
when i try to access this api proxy
apigee would block it
since we didn't pass an api key
malicious clients could still send a lot
of requests and interrupt
traffic processing by the gateway for
legitimate users
so to further protect this api i created
a very basic rule in cloud armor
for the simplicity of this demo this
rule checks for the api key header
though it doesn't validate the actual
key itself
i'm now going to apply this rule to the
apogee load balancer
and apply this policy to the target
now when i go to the load balancing
section under network services
and look into the details of the load
balancer
i see that the security policy has cloud
armor attached to it
let's now try once again to access the
same hello world api without passing any
api key
you'll notice that the error this time
is at a network level from cloud armor
if the same api is accessed with a
header and an invalid api key
then cloud armor is going to clear it
but apogee would do further validation
and block it due to faulty api key that
was just a preview of how to add
multi-layer security for your apis with
apogee and cloud armor
in summary apogee and cloud armor offer
integrated
out of the box security capabilities to
protect your apis
at multiple levels now it's your turn to
try it out
and get started by following the links
in the description box below
[Music]
you